o la bienvenue à la poste yves academy
venez avec moi on va préparer une belle
salade de saison
[Musique]
on va commencer par blanchir du coup les
petits pois trois minutes dans l'eau on
va laver les épinards si vous utilisez
ce type d pinardon des grandes feuilles
faudra juste laisser penser pour les
rendre un peu plus agréable en bouche
ensuite je m'occupais des taillez les
courgettes en tagliatelles donc pour
cela vous pouvez soit utiliser
l'économe où on peut aussi utiliser une
mandoline
on va faire sauter rapidement les
asperges avec un petit peu d'huile
d'olive et de l'ail écrasé dans une
poêle de les couper en biseau dans une
poêle qui est déjà bien chaude
je rajoute les asperges et après je
rajoute bail enfin c'est vraiment le
faire sauter trois minutes pour préparer
la sauce on va simplement et mixer tous
les ingrédients dans son bled
donc on va commencer par une autre
avocat on va faire 40 g des noix de
cajou 2 cuillères à soupe d'huile
d'olive procuration de tamari on va
mettre une bonne pente poignée de débat
seul hic les jus d'un citron 1 citron et
demi j'ai rajouté juste un petit peu
d'eau pour aider les tours ces mecs et
[Musique]
maintenant je rajoute mes petits pois et
je rajoute la soci on va passer au
dressage en gt3 fraises j'ai rajouté
l'ososphère j et puis j'aime bien finir
avec un petit peu dégradée ces cinq
voilà notre salade et les prête ça nous
a pris peut-être quinze minutes pour la
préparer vous avez un plat qui est
coloré kiev rec et des saisons et je
suis sûr que vous allez vous régaler